[Music]
this is a retractable sword okay and
maybe you've noticed but you have a long
hose I did they put this I don't know I
don't know exactly this is about well
Eric I don't know who this guy is but
there's a lot of trust in this second
awesome so Eric hooking up a blood tube
to you yes so basically this is the
retractable samurai sword
it doesn't hurt too much I mean there's
a little bit of pain with it but once
you press it in it collapses onto itself
okay and then at that point Eric will
release a giant flow of blood and it's
your job at that point to really sell
this like you're getting stabbed by me
okay I'm a very good actor okay so here
we go
Eric are you ready for this hold on hold
it well you make sure you're ready you
really see the blood flow right you
ready all right Bloods coming all right
that hurts the illusion a little bit
overall
[Applause]
and actually had actually had this
problem
okay so I'm gonna happen are we all set
are we ready to go so I'm gonna I'm
gonna stick my sword inside okay can we
just make sure you know what you're
doing it's gonna go right in here I'm
wearing a little bit of protective
covering that here just say okay I'm
gonna have to press pretty hard so make
sure you don't move because if you move
off the powder it gets your hand it's
gonna puncture you so just saw better
but then no I'm going to come to my
rescue because blood would shoot out you
would think the effect is going
perfectly and I would die possible okay
here we go three two
[Applause]
[Applause]